c'est quoi pour l'ascension de vous
chanter tout le temps ici par exemple un
maxime kenny c'est quoi donc je sens que
tout le temps c'est qui alors vous c'est
quoi
elle rit tanoh je mange mange mange mon
bateau gitana team one off
un jour je perds c'est un vrai problème
je n'arrive pas à retenir les paroles
des chansons d'abba cas on va leur en
anglais en français du laxisme et de
cinéma le cinéma c'était bien
[Applaudissements]
bouh c'est quoi ton michel moi c'est le
chanteur malheureux de cloclo asie et je
me demande si tu existes encore et je me
demande c'est ton coeur et au nord
s'cusez moi tu fais pour le soupçon
dépression après ça permet chanson hey
boy bambara clopeau les espèces
aujourd'hui sur maxime plein
d'attentions j'ai une dent qu'il de
cinéma et un brise glace et vous vous en
pensez quoi vous couture sont comme un
fps sheeran
mais ce n'est pas vrai a chanté je sais
pas chanter mais s'il me ça va la crs y
pleut dehors mais la shoah les
repreneurs a dit de manière sûre
castaldi ah oui non non rien une vraie
morale quand même acabit tient sans
doute à moi ou elle va y aller là où
sévit un fou fr brûlé au vent bélanger
qui flanche
merci est ce que j'ai pu pour mettre une
s'il vous plaît vraiment plaisir
[Applaudissements]
avec lui j'ai appris qu'il avait été
bien géré a dit mme moi j'aime bien
lucho battisti alors je chanterai à
peine soit et aoued à quoi ça c'est quoi
c'est une chanson de pizzérias annoncé
une très très belle chance ait jamais se
sont dits oui la casse à peine sauter
avant les open sauter si on a de
mozzarella lot merci à payer de mots car
il va arriver tout seul là à merci
et vous jean-luc j'ai attrapé ça allait
mal et les sharks au chant d'ailleurs
s'il attrape un couturier faut qu'ils
mettent de la craie vilaine peau de
roule
non mais c'est vrai mais c'est quelque
chose qui se pratique les six mois en
reçoit tous cas vous n'essayez pas si
vous voulez je peux espérer vous voulez
mais c'est isabelle bas il est d'accord
tu vas hivernage arrive
j'arrive à lui que vous inconnu voilà
mais vous rigolez mais non sa chanson
préférée c'est quoi oui c'est pas son
préféré mois vous n'aimez pas surpris
parce qu'elles recherchent toutes les
chansons mais bien souvent c'est bien
sûr c'est gbagbo les olé à chaque année
des lads en appel qui est mimi mathy
non mais
[Musique]
la vie
on avoir fini ma cuti non garde pour
qu'ils ont été la chanson